so you're a larry fan well i mean
larry's my guy yeah he's the best he is
the best he's just trying to get you
away with respect to louis he's the
true king of comedy now he is very good
i opened for larry david years ago when
he was a stand-up what was his stand-up
like
brilliant and impossible to i i was the
emc actually okay
and a guy named bob shaw was a headliner
he was a great comic
and uh larry was this feature act it was
in cambridge massachusetts at the
catch rising star and uh so they told me
you have to watch this guy's whole set
because he blows up and leaves a lot he
walks off stage a lot he won't do a lot
of times he won't finish his second gets
angry
so they said you have to stay in the
room and be ready to jump on
and oh not for joy no no
yeah in case you just leave her i
thought he was like you got to see this
you're saying we need you to be stand by
okay
and i didn't know anything about him i
never heard of him and he he instantly
became my favorite comedian the
audiences didn't know what to do with
him
but he had these great bits like um
he says i could um if if i was
complimented by joseph mengele i would
have liked him like if he paid me
larry david your hair looks good today
oh really dramatically
yeah oh yeah oh yeah dr michael thank
you you mentally not a bad guy
and he does the thing about
anti-semitism at country clubs okay and
he says that where he's experienced it
was that sometimes when you're putting
they'll say stuff to put you off the
guy's like hey larry how about the six
million that's a pretty accessible no go
ahead put but you know just weird
stories very funny some of them that
became episodes oh really he did a story
a story on stage about leaving a message
for a woman that was so embarrassing on
her answering machine that he had to
break into her apartment and steal
the tape that was a bit of his
it's an episode of seinfeld yeah yeah so
uh but anyway he was but him he would
get really angry like santa would be
quietly ordering
a beer like really people were very
polite and he'd go how could you be so
rude what kind of person you need to
start screaming at them and he throw
money at people take your money back and
leave you [ __ ] animals
he just gets so angry and after a few
shows one night he really bombed
and the crowd was great they were like
the best crowd we'd ever seen that's his
problem and after the show he said uh he
said what'd you think that crowd they
were awful weren't they were they awful
they were rude and just noisy and bad
and it wasn't true
but i said yeah yeah guys just being
polite he goes well why don't you do
something about you're the host you're
supposed to know
that's all there is to control the room
yeah it was a nightmare have you talked
about him uh to him about that since
yeah i i auditioned for the show once
again and he said i remember you i
remember catch rise i remember we worked
together i didn't recount to him right
how impossible he was
i just said yeah yeah cause i was trying
to get a job
but i love i love larry yeah he's great
yeah he's like one to me it's like the
most pure it's like he can't help how
irritated he is i like that that's the
kind of comedy i like is the folks that
can't help it yeah and
if i can say something about yours which
i really appreciate please don't feel
uncomfortable you're already wrinkling
the brow is that there's this feeling
that it's falling out of you
there are certain people that like like
chris and i love chris i grew up on
chris and chris is like this is how it
is this is how it's right and yours is
almost like it's like i just can't yeah
and there's something about it where
and i've watched you know obviously
you're coming by the cell or something
like that and like i kind of watch and
especially live when you watch something
that's you know taped you're like i know
that this was prepared but watching it
live yeah it feels like it's just
happening
this is just happening yeah and that's a
bit of fakery i did it as well we all
have it yes because you you and the
tricky thing is when bits start killing
because a lot of stuff that i do is
uncomfortable when i start saying it and
i'm uncomfortable because they are yeah
but i push through it and find a joke
and together we find
joy in a scary place that's what i like
to do but when bits start killing
because i know mechanically how to make
them work and i know this path i get a
little smug and i start doing jokes that
are like you know super offensive about
pedophiles and just talking about hey
this is going to kill it always kills
yeah and then the crowds look at me like
what are you why are you so confident
about this
and then i readjust to like oh yeah this
isn't easy to talk about but let's get
there together
um so that's that's my tricky thing to
manage you know yeah i wonder if it was
that authenticity
that kind of cut through the mess like
when people found you they're like this
guy's just kind of like talking right
now like
this i'm going to make a weird
comparison go for it but do you know
when i first saw kings of comedy i don't
know if you watch great movie yeah great
i and i was so young i didn't know that
bernie was telling jokes
and i was like you're just watching a
dude fall apart in front of you this is
the funniest human he was the best he
was the first year i ever did the first
year they ever had the aspen comedy
festival which came and went yeah yeah
the first year they had it they didn't
know to segregate the shows it's a funny
thing
because comedy festivals are always like
they have urban nights yeah yeah yeah
yeah but they didn't just it was a new
festival so like let's just put
comedians together and there was one
show that was like an all-week show that
was me mark maron
bernie mac and cedric the entertainer
all four of us and it was one of the
best shows i ever was part of
to be in with those guys and bernie i
mean force the one of the best comics
ever to me is bernie have you seen the
five-minute set he did
for deaf comedy jam
radio [ __ ] yes it's the best so
the best mark and i were talking about
this is it
is it the best just five minutes of a
performance in comedy
no i mean it's been a lot of great
five-minute performances there has but
like it wasn't even the jokes right it
was him reacting to this thing that
happened created a
energy
yes he walked into he made def jam into
something interesting i mean def jam was
powerful
it was like if but he turned it he
turned it into something else yes it's
like if billboard philadelphia was an
audition set that's right yeah i mean
because jim made your career billboard
philadelphia was a one-off that got
captured on camera and then blew the
[ __ ] up yeah he just thought this is the
set i'm in it let's get the [ __ ] out
bernie's like this makes or breaks my
career people are bombing [ __ ]
everything this is what i'm gonna do for
five minutes that's crazy to me just
call the audible on the biggest moment
of your career and say this is what it
is and then bury it yes and some and
both of those had this something in
common which is
not comfortable feeling attacked
not happy to be there yeah
but in control of it yeah and and
weapons great great jokes yeah that's a
an enormous that's and if that's
lightning in a bottle it's very hard to
yeah it should be hard yeah it should be
a hard thing to achieve yeah yeah i
don't want to say like you shouldn't be
able to recreate it every time but the
magic of doing it yeah
that's the tricky thing about comedy is
you you it's it is a live thing yeah i
think that's and one problem that
comedians have when they make specials i
think is trying to get it trying to be
slick
and trying to be in control you want it
to be your great night you want to be
like a rock star
you want to be like perry como and just
be like hey man watch me work yeah yeah
and i want to show that i'm killing and
there's you know yeah there's smoke in
the room it's beautiful but that's not
what comedy is at its best sometimes it
messes up sometimes people interrupt how
do you make it organic how do you make
it pure
in that moment
well you know but also you want to be
good you want to actually do it well
yeah but i remember i was getting ready
for a special once and i thought and i
was talking to chris rock who's a great
mentor he's always giving me great
advice and i said i think i'm gonna take
a month off before i shoot so that i'm
fresh i've been working really hard and
he said that's a really dumb idea he
said you need to be prepared and i go
but i want to be fresh he and he said
it's i don't even i think he made this
up it's better to be prepared and
pretend to be fresh than it is to be
fresh and pretend to be prepared do you
agree
a hundred percent but there's you can
move the that line somewhere where it's
just
where you want it to be because because
it's just different it's a different
product that's all yeah it's great to
watch a guy master a set yes but it's
also super one thing i used to love
listen to
is jim um
florentine
on xm radio i like listening to xm
comedy because they just anyone can send
a tape in yeah and you hear some really
[ __ ] rough stuff yeah and he was and
some of them are just don't there's just
somebody who sounds really unsure
and they're talking about their family
and the crowd's not with them yeah
but florentine is in some place in
jersey and he's getting heckled he's oh
is that right sir is that right i'm of
[ __ ] what well [ __ ] you and he's just
he's always sounds like he's uh like
there's a lot of b you can smell the
beer in the place
so
uh yeah i like i like comedy that way
too
what do you think is saying
real quick on florentine florentine had
an amazing joke at the rich vos roast
did you see the rich foster yes he stole
the show he's amazing bro one of his one
of his jokes was uh he goes bonnie
really lived the american dream uh she
moved to america and got stupid rich
yeah
that's the best joke in the world that's
amazing that's a great joke that's a
great roast i love it
bonnie goes uh bobby kelly you're up
next so if you want to start making your
way up here
that's a great roast oh dude it was so
good you can get it at a rich voss
roast i think it's on youtube no oh they
probably gonna hate me for saying that
buy it there and support it but yeah i
love richie's [ __ ] way but yeah
florentine has some amazing [ __ ]
videos man that's good i love that we
complimented bonnie and
jim but we're like we love rich also
his name's in the website you can you
can get it there yeah you were saying
about it
i i think makes you think it's sinbad
because it's always fresh he'll go up
i think the way he got to start is he
just had somebody read the newspaper and
then he did
a whole five minutes on that and then he
said
i want the joke to be different every
single time mm-hmm i want if you come to
two shows in a row the joke is always a
little bit different for you yeah that
was my goal when i started doing
stand-up when i when i found out as a
young i wanted to be a stamp comic that
the people tell the same jokes every
night yeah i was i was uh
it really is and i i had a goal to do
this a different show every time yeah i
never got that chris chris broke that
for me rock broke that for me well yeah
because when i got more into it i like
watching guys yeah watching him
when you're a child it's all fresh to
you it's all like that that's why i
don't think any comics should do the
thing that they all can't stop doing
which is i told that joke in this place
you're not living enough yeah yeah it's
just a big they go what yeah yeah yeah
you've said this to other people it
explains for the people maybe who don't
know as much as i make still tell a joke
and it's to make fun of a place so
they'll make a joke that's
one version of it there are many yeah
they make a joke about something
intelligent i don't know what the joke
is that they think is intelligent and
then they go i told that joke in
mississippi and this guy was like what
yeah or they have something that
happened that was funny in the moment
yeah
a funny exchange where they were clever
to the person yeah so they like i i told
that joke one time and this guy said
this and guess what i said yeah you're
just in a mess of what are you doing
yeah why are you doing this but i think
that's an example of when you're not
like living enough yourself right like i
think that we can get so obsessed with
stand-up and only going on stage and not
actually your stories about last time i
was on stage something's wrong we're
going dry yeah but sinbad i remember
brian regan was another just
electrically great comic one of the best
of all time
he worked with sinbad once like open
forum at a club for a week like way
years ago he told me the story that they
were hanging out in the daytime it used
to be you'd like work at club with
somebody then you'd hang out all day
and so like they're waiting for a bus
and it's taking a long time and sinbad's
like man this
bus is never coming and he goes oh then
he writes writes it down okay
and uh so then that night he watches
sinbad and he goes you ever been waiting
for the bus it's like this bus is not
coming damn man the bus never comes and
that was it like
[Laughter]
all day he would write jokes and the
jokes were just wet hat what he said
during the day mcdonald's said it when
he did montreal sinbad again montreal is
another thing that makes your whole
career
he has like his tie seven minutes norm
does it he's worked on forever him and
sinbad are gonna buy socks the day of
the show or the night before the show
and then it's like super hard to buy
socks and then norm goes out and does
his tight seven minutes gets in gets out
does it like he rehearsed it a thousand
times sinbad goes up he's like yo why is
it so hard to buy socks in montreal
whole set on socks for crushes yeah yeah
so he had what something that these
stories tell you in common is that
sinbad hangs out he's a nice guy yeah
hangs out with other comics hmm he says
you want go back
you know he's one of the most moderate
was that harder for you as you got more
famous and there are more people like
wanting things from you like in your
heyday was it hard hard for you you're
the big guy right now you no no i
dominate most of that yeah i mean
i don't give as much space for other
people no no but i just feel like you
were in a different position because i
think you had more platforms to give
opportunities yeah you know like when
you have a show i think every time
there's an interaction it's like you
you're almost auditioning oh am i going
to be on this new season i mean i did
give a lot of guys uh youtubers in my
show a lot of a lot of people in my show
were comics i love you using comedians
why um
first of all i like
stand-up comics it's my community i love
them
and i care about them i mean it's goofy
but i do
and so uh
and i like
seeing somebody and thinking what if you
gave him a shot and seeing what happens
um like i remember i was in australia
it's the only time i ever went there and
i went to melbourne first
and i went into a comedy club and it was
the only place i'd been for a long time
that nobody knew who i was
and there was a young kid there named
rob something thomas
anyways a young really
really nerdy nervous guy and all his
jokes were perfect and the crowd was
like what is this [ __ ] but then they
started loving his jokes and i was going
the next night to sydney to play the big
opera house
and like the only building in the whole
country that anybody recognizes yeah and
so i said to this kid why don't you come
with me to sydney open for me he lost it
and he was like oh i don't i do i had he
said i have a gig in adelaide but i'll
try to get out of it
and he got out of his gig and i took him
and i loved being in the wings what and
he was looking at his set list
and he looked and i said to him i've
been in this position a lot i've given
somebody a shot yeah and i said don't
worry about the spectacle just these
jokes just think about your jokes yeah
and and he destroyed another person like
that was lynn copplets
a woman who i love she's so funny
and she spun her wheels for a lot of
years just she's a seller comic works
hard yeah but nobody was going after
lynn coppolis for a big great
perspective too yes like lynn's comedic
perspective i think is really
interesting really unique and very raw
and real yeah and uh i didn't even know
her that was how we became friends i was
doing the garden and i had a couple
openers and i thought i wanted one more
and i just told somebody get lynn
copplets tonight to open for me at the
garden and she came to madison square
garden
and uh she was
serious and nervous i had hope for her
because she wasn't yeah like nervous
like talking she was just serious locked
in and she went up there and it was like
the stars a star is born like she was
wearing this flowy thing and she was
just out to the crowd yeah and they were
in love with her and it killed me it
made me so happy it's like the best
feeling you'll emotionally even think
about it i do it makes me want to cry it
was a beautiful feeling we've been very
close since then yeah but that is so
rewarding to me it's almost in a sense
it can be better than personal success
on stage because you don't get to enjoy
your work that way you're in the middle
of it you're in the middle you've got to
deliver yeah you can't go like this is
great yeah but you can do it when it's
somebody else yeah yeah